c'est la répression la plus sanglante
depuis la prise de pouvoir du président
ivan du quai depuis le 28 avril dernier
de nombreuses manifestations contre le
gouvernement colombien sont organisées
dans le pays
au coeur de cette colère populaire un
projet de hausse des impôts pour faire
face à l'impact économique de la
pandémie
ce mardi le défenseur du peuple entités
publiques de protection des droits
humains a fait état de 42 morts en 13
jours 41 civils et un membre de la force
publique
les ong locales elle évoque un bilan de
47 morts dont 39 par la violence
policière tandis que le ministère de la
défense recense 849 agents et 700 civils
blessés une répression qui a accentué le
mécontentement du peuple colombien lors
d'une conférence à cali ce mardi le
président tempère la situation et
apporte son soutien aux forces de
sécurité
la foi de sa poule à toi
nos forces de sécurité agissent dans le
respect absolu de la constitution et de
la loi
les ordres opérationnels sont toujours
émis dans le cadre garantissant le
respect des droits de l'homme
et si des violations ont lieu suite à
des initiatives individuelles de membres
des forces de sécurité
elles sont l'objet de poursuites et d'
enquête est à 0 déjà les jeunes smb st
gall face à cette mobilisation sociale
sanglante
le gouvernement affirme avoir pris de
nombreux sanctions contre les abus
policiers à cali les manifestants
témoignent de la violence des autorités
ils ont commencé à organiser des marches
pacifiques des réunions des chants des
pétitions au fil des heures
ils ont commencé à avancer et les choses
ont changé
la police colombienne anti émeute a
commencé à venir
à mettre plus de pression a lancé des
gaz lacrymogènes
le commissaire gouvernemental pour la
paix et à d'ores et déjà annoncé la
suspension de cinq agents mais les
sanctions ont été jugées trop légères
selon le comité régional de grève qui a
rencontré le président à cali ce mardi
une rencontre qui n'a mené à aucun
accord le comité appelle donc à une
nouvelle journée de grèves et de
manifestations ce mercredi si la réforme
fiscale a été retiré le dôme et la
mobilisation perdure contre la
répression policière dans un pays où la
pauvreté et frôle désormais les 43% et
où les inégalités se creusent de plus en
plus